bruno parmentier conférencier ingénieur
économiste spécialisé dans les questions
agricoles et alimentaires est notre
invité ce soir merci d'être avec nous
bonjour bonsoir alors tout d'abord
beaucoup d'experts et je pense que vous
en faites partie disent que cette guerre
en ukraine fera sans doute plus de morts
par la famine dans les pays du sud que
par les bombes dans cet horrible conflit
est-ce que c'est à craindre
oui malheureusement je suis vraiment
désolé de dire ça mais malheureusement
oui c'est à dire notamment en afrique il
ya pratiquement aucun pays africain qui
soit autosuffisant en nourriture et
particulièrement sur les céréales il
faut se rendre compte que les pays qui
ont besoin d'acheter des céréales y en a
beaucoup mais les pays qui sont capables
d'en vendre il y en a très peu et
concrètement pour le blé
c'est la russie les états unis le canada
l'ukraine la france un peu l'allemagne
c'est quasiment tôt c'est pas les pays
qui produisent le plus c'est les
produits c'est les pays qui produisent
plus que ce qu'ils mangent parce que les
deux pays qui produisent le plus de de
céréales
c'est la chine elana mais ils mangent
leurs céréales en revanche la russie et
l'ukraine ne produisent ensemble que 15%
du blé mondial mais assure 40 à 45% des
exportations
donc quand vous êtes un pays africain
vous avez besoin d'acheter du blé ben
c'est normal vous allez vers l'arc
rennes l'ukraine et la russie alors la
russie ça peut-être marcher le cren là
cette année c'est quasiment terminé et
en plus la chine qui d'habitude est au
sous autosuffisante ah c'est une
mauvaise récolte l'an dernier ce qui
fait qu'elle est devenue un gros
importateur auquel elle concurrence
encore plus et ça va durer parce que eux
probablement le cren ne va pas semaine
il récoltait de blé cette année et que
pour qu on puisse faire de bonnes
récoltes de céréales il faut des engrais
or justement le cren la russie
et la biélorussie sont de gros
producteurs de gaz qui est la matière
première des engrais azotés et gros
producteur d'engrais on va en parler des
engrais on va en parler bruno parmentier
j'ai une autre question avant justement
de passer à 7 sept autres points il se
peut aussi que que cette crise
alimentaire provoque des émeutes de la
faim et même des révoltes et peut-être
même dès guerre
écoutait en 2007
le prix des céréales a triplé il ya eu
des émeutes de la faim de 36 pays et des
normes déstabilisation
géopolitique
trois ans après en 2010 de nouveau le
prix des céréales augmente et chattez
une cause directe issime des printemps
arabes
le prix des céréales est déjà nettement
plus élevé qu'en 2007 et en 2010
ça n'a pas fini ça va augmenter et sa
nature et ça va durer au moins toute
cette année 2022 donc les mêmes causes
produisent les mêmes effets
malheureusement un les gens quand ils
ont vraiment faim c'est la différence
entre manger un peu et ne plus de manger
du tout mais vous savez c'est vieux
comme le monde qu'est-ce qui manque
qu'un place de la bastille en france en
1789 du pain ça provoqué la révolution
française donc malheureusement dans
beaucoup de pays où il ya déjà beaucoup
d'injustices peu de solidarité et déjà
des difficultés à se nourrir les gens
vont vraiment avoir faim j'imagine
qu'ils vont protester